one of the things about coming back was
that one of the problems about all this
was the key you guys for how many years
you do not talk for yeah quite a bit I
love my man yeah sadly yeah no I don't
like sound it's an awful thing you know
you really like each other you loved
working together and and then it and
what was it was a one bus stop or was it
a dribbling part that was just a fit it
was just over a film that was a
misunderstanding and a mishandling of it
was us it was just over a film that is
at the beach yeah yes and it did it's a
big regret of mine that it went on for
so very long
it's a shame we didn't work together all
those years not because of any
particular film and it didn't really
matter about the beach it was never
about the beach it was about our
friendship and the phone how much I felt
like Danny's I was in through the first
three movies you know shallow graves
transporting then a life less ordinary
and then I wasn't in the force and I was
a bit made me a bit rudderless I didn't
quite get it and then yeah we didn't we
didn't speak for a long time which is
such a waste because I agree so it began
with a lunch was is the lunch when it
when you told him he wasn't going to be
in the beach yeah and I think we can't I
handled it very very badly and I've
apologized to you and I kind of feel
ashame about it that's very difficult to
you know it's one of the things weirdly
that the films about is about trying to
express emotions and I felt a great
shame about it really I was not proud of
the way I handled it and he actually
handled it with enormous grace because
you know you see these actors and they
do big things and you hear these stories
about them and he handles all his world
with enormous grace and courage actually
which is the definition of grace they
say courage is grace under pressure
which he showed enormously so and we had
this thing we had this filmed this
Slumdog Millionaire which was doing a
managing picking up all these amazing
things and and somebody asked him he
didn't tell me something asked him
whether he'd present this kind of
promotional award to me on one of the
things you do on the route to the Oscars
and stuff like that and he did and he
stood up on stage and he made this
amazing speech and I was like in tears
backstage it was like for God so yeah
well I'm very grateful to him
and when this happens in my life and
friends of mine this has happened I
always really unsuccessfully try to
interfere and broker a peace did any of
you try to get involved what did you get
the world leaving that alone we had our
own kids going on no one loves you in
India I was really upset but it sorts it
actually good to beat you Danny but very
quickly very late it was I was reading
because there were something I was
reading about this down is not to know
and I was reading letters and there's a
story there's a story that I don't know
who told the story or how it ended up
the papers with the story and I'm
reading the story and I'm thinking ah
this is obviously the lovely moment when
they buried the hatchet came together
talk us through the flight back from was
it Shanghai was involved in a $50 oh I'm
in the plane to Shanghai to promote a
movie and someone says you know who the
head of the jury it's my went normally
Danny Boyle they're gonna be delighted
and each other like things and it was a
bit awkward and anyway then we come back
home because we're all stupid
celebrities we were flying first class
and it was only three of us in force
plus Danny
me and my wife EV and we're flying back
and were scattered around and then ed
falls asleep and her light goes off and
I'm sitting there and down is lights on
and my lights on and I'm thinking this
is it this is the moment and I'm
slightly behind so I can see that I
think this is this is when we just get
it all out and I was I'll say I'm sorry
Neil zoom story and we'll get on with it
and we couldn't we just sat there with
our lights burning
Oh put you back together now we're nor
near if you'd like to see even more
stuff like that then hit subscribe or
don't free world but I know what I do in
that situation